you
rarely remember when a tournament goes
well it's
just kind of what they're supposed to do
the competitors show up
a winner is crowned and everyone goes
home lovely stuff
when they go badly though you
never forget they basically stay seared
into our collective memories and become
the stuff of legend
these are the top 10 tournament mishaps
starting us off at number 10 we have a
zubu frost cheating
at worlds 2012. season 2 world saw tsm
face off against south korea's azubu
frost in the quarter finals
now on the surface it looked like
business as usual for azubu frost
as they comfortably two-owed north
america's first seed trying to stop that
path to the championship
and a double frost will knock out team
solomid
five days later though riot dropped a
bombshell from the league of legends
forums ryan vice president of esports
dustin beck outlined that korean team
azubu frost has been found guilty of
unsportsmanlike conduct
riot's investigation concluded that
during game one
a zubu frost 80 carry womb looked at the
large venue monitor that showed the
location of
all players in the game which
incidentally
was literally right behind him during
play
tsm's mid laner and owner reginald
released a statement clarifying the
accusations
we looked straight to zoom frost and
chaos notices
their players looking at our map looking
at the mini-map and
they start like talking this was
followed by a ping on the mini map
right where tsm were moving into
position for an invade
there's also proof in the replay that
there's been pings at dark areas
where we're standing where they have no
vision of and shy's shot blast into the
brush
was enough to confirm riot's suspicions
although riot slapped the team with a
fine they felt wound screen watching
didn't explicitly help azubu frost win
the game
and so the result was unchanged that's
gotta hurt for tsm
the enemy team literally cheats and riot
still says they would have lost anyway
moving on to number nine now we have
chicken the lobby raider at esl one
katowice 2015.
everybody who's played or watched a
little cs go is familiar
with the game's population of lovable
killable
chickens but for this entry we're
looking at the slightly
differently spelled chicken the
notorious lobby raider that became
famous for
busting into the games of big streamers
it went from community meme to
tournament trolling during esl one
katowice
2015 when the enigmatic chicken popped
up
in the envious versus ninjas in pajamas
semi-final lobby
now despite imploring that he was a
friendly chicken
the silver-ranked poultry prankster kept
getting repeatedly kicked
and we're just going to wait for envious
choice for the side on dust2
in the lobby here really he really wants
to play he has a good rank as well
you can see that he has a level to play
in the semi-final you know
the chicken chicken became a minor
celebrity
even doing a reddit ama at one point
although he hasn't popped up for a few
years now the legendary lobby raider has
definitely secured his place in
counter-strike history
coming in at number eight now we have
valkyrie's invincible
fortnight win ray
she wasn't even dying hey screenshot
get the question get the clip the former
100 thieves streamer was taking part in
fortnight's 2019 twitch rivals
when she realized that somehow she was
immune to the storm damage outside of
the final circle
i'm hacking what do i do
i'm not taking storm damage now you
don't need to play fortnite to realize
what an
insane game-breaking advantage this
really is
after a little bit of dancing in the
rain valkyrie swooped into the tiny
circle to take the win
oh my god my god dude it doesn't
even matter i'm so sorry she tweeted out
that it was
unintentional hacking and promptly
disqualified herself
godly invincibility to the storm and
honesty a great combination to have
coming in at number seven we're taking
you back to the pgl major krakow 2017
and the infamous cs go crouch jump bug
just jumping up the flashbang as well
once a spot player flash down and now
tabs him to potentially get two or three
kills in that spot
essentially players discovered that if
they jumped while behind
certain pieces of map cover and crouched
they could peak enemies but were not
seen
at all by those that they saw but it's
not from the realm of possibility that
we get two or three challenging teams in
especially with g2 as a challenging team
cloud nine how they played in cologne
tabs in
how he's playing right now for big as he
goes aggressive
this actually resulted in all 16 teams
at the tournament
shaking on a gentleman's agreement to
not
use the crouch jump the bug was fixed a
few weeks later
so that the wall peeker can always be
peeked back
now i hate getting disconnected from a
game but for a lot of us
it's just something we have to put up
with if there's one place
you don't expect internet problems
though it's a world
that's exactly what happened to clg eu
and world elite though
as they faced off during the season two
worlds quarter finals
that's right they got disconnected from
the server
during worlds even in the last game
especially
20 health 30 health near the end of
those if they hadn't built
one eternity later let's get things
underway so if you've just joined us it
has been a very
long break between as the broadcast team
scrambled to cover for the technical
difficulties
riot decided to remake the whole game
despite the fact that 12 minutes and two
kills
had come to pass the next game went
without a hitch but
it wasn't to last game three saw a
59-minute slugfest that
looked like it was just about to reach
its conclusion before the internet
clapped out once again
they are going to go for this fight
so after almost an hour of gameplay that
meant
nothing riot decided to remake once
again with the exact same picks and bans
third time's the charm right eventually
it was decided that the elusive third
game
would be rescheduled for five days later
at the same venue that was to be used
for the semi-finals and finals
they had those three hard-earned days
and it was definitely a hard one game
for clg for our number five entry we're
taking you to the warcraft 3
open at dreamhack anaheim 2020. now just
like our last entry it was
played with disconnection problems but
the most crushing example
has to be the quarter-finals between
moon and thor zane
thor'zen clawed himself into an upset
position
he smelt blood the crowd was ready to go
but the connection was not
a disconnect i'm gonna assume thousand
dropped but i feel like moon was
on the way to holding this attack oh
wow as per the rules they restarted the
game
soon enough thor zane found himself with
over a 1
000 gold advantage and looking to close
it out once again
and looks like another drop just happens
by the third attempt to play the final
game of this series
moon seemed to have learned from his
past mistakes and took down the
unfortunate thor zane in what will be
remembered as an
absolute disaster of a series
moving on to number four we have wild
turtles heatwave disaster
the kovid 19 pandemic forced the lcs
summer split 2020
to be played out online and for the most
part things have gone without a hitch
that was until game two of the finals
between tsm
and flyquest during the second game
flyquest wild turtle
was killed in a turret dive and appeared
to rage quit the game
as a result and you just saw for a
second there the
wild turtles disconnected message down
there that was the time when there was
the pause for the belief bug that didn't
exist and during that was the disconnect
so
fortunately the disconnect wasn't a rage
quit
unfortunately it was because wild turtle
had lost
power in his apartment building due to
the heatwave outages that had been
hitting the la
area at the time we're waiting for an
update from dwp but they told us last
night there were about
70 000 customers without power and so
cal edison had about 24 000 customers in
the dark in la and orange counties
in an unprecedented move wild turtle had
to travel to flyquest training facility
in order to continue the series it was
turtle versus the la
traffic moving on to number three we've
got the side switch controversy
that was sonic fox versus goichi at the
evo 2018
grand finals
[Music]
there is one thing about evo is that you
see the celebration but there's also
always the heartbreak in 2018 sonic fox
and goichi
faced off in the grand finals at evo
2018 in what was said to be another
thrilling installment of their
legendary rivalry in dragon ball
fighters goichi handily won the first
match
3-0 and it looked like he was about to
carry that momentum straight into the
next match
and win the tournament that was until
sonic fox requested a
side switch to the player one side of
the stage
oh he's like so he's like so what what's
happening here is
yeah the question sonic fox is
apparently asking is if there can be a
side switch
in between the sets he wants player one
now
but the rules say nah son you gotta stay
right
there while this was actually allowed by
the rules
it took five minutes to translate this
request to goichi
by the time the swap had happened the
momentum from his recent sweet bad
all but dissipated sonic fox had in
effect
iced their opponent i i don't know it
might be a stretch
but santa fox maybe did that just to
call the man off sonic fox took the next
step 3-0
becoming the world's best dragon ball
fighters player
so was the stall an unfortunate
coincidence
or a clever tactic the world may never
[Applause]
ball know evolution 2018
champion grappling into the number two
spot we have the notorious the fabled
the disreputable fountain hook
that was the biggest joke i've ever seen
the fountain hook was a dota 2 exploit
that rocketed to fame
during the international 2013. natas
vincere had their backs against the wall
in the final game of the winners finals
versus
tong fu it was going to require
something incredibly special
and a little bit insane to turn the tide
and they got it
in the form of the fountain hook still
hasn't even been used there's a hook
hell brought all the way back to the
base
cleaned up by the fountain the series
then devolved into a game of dodge the
meat hook
as natas vincere slowly clawed and
hooked their way back into the game
he got him one more
this is what you call one
for the road the unintended mechanic
divided opinion
while there were those that called for a
bug fix others
passionately defended its place in the
game let them try this thing
they can do it go and try this thing you
have to respect the skill that it took
for those fountain hooks to happen
if it was completely broken and super
easy to do everyone would be doing it
a few months later though valve
responded to calls that the fountain
hook was a glitch
and made it so that the meat hook would
only drag enemies to where
pudge cast the ability
and finally at number one we have the
bayonetta blunder that
was the smash 4 grand finals from evo
2018. the grand final saw
bayonetta main captain zack face off
against bayonetta main
lima for most people this obnoxious
mirror match
was bearable until this happened
what's going on what is this i don't
know i was stalling for time all right
man
i really understand why this is the last
evo
[Laughter]
that's even for you i mean i really get
it both players
held b charging bayonetta's bullets and
just having a friendly chat with each
other
for just under two whole minutes
it was not the fight fans had turned up
to see they even had time for a
mid-game interview oh they're actually
doing an interview
is this real i can't tell this act i
feel like this is actually we're doing
an interview right now
right here it actually took officials
waving the rule books line about game
stalling
in their face for the pair to finally
play it out
oh dad dad yeah
yo bear came up there with the rules in
the rules it said you were not allowed
to start the match
for many fans this bayonetta spectacle
really tainted the memory of smash 4's
final evo appearance
last a champion is proud at evo 2018.
alright guys that is all i have for you
today but i do want to know which one of
those was your favorite now for me
personally it has to be the disconnect
ones
there is something so unbearable about
watching players and teams have to
remake game after game
i can't stand it hopefully improving
technology
will mean that's a thing of the past but
who knows there's always going to be
a problem at some tournaments somewhere
that's just the way it goes
thanks for watching leave a like if you
enjoy the video subscribe if you want to
make sure you don't miss any of our
videos and i'll see you all in the next
one
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages